tras 36 días levantan la huelga en Santa
Cruz de la sierra la cámara de diputados
bolivianas decidió que el censo que
había frenado el presidente Luis Arce se
celebrará el 23 de marzo de 2024
[Música]
también contribuya a la participación a
la unidad de nuestro país y ojalá que
hoy
empiecen también a levantarse la medida
de presión que nunca fueron necesarias
la ley fue aprobada por dos tercios de
la cámara baja y fue enviada al senado
para su revisión antes de que sea
promulgada por el presidente Arce el
censo el primero en más de una década
permitirá que los escaños del Congreso
sean redistribuidos antes de las
elecciones generales de 2025
la oposición había acusado al gobierno
de querer retrasarlo ya que el
oficialismo podría salir afectado en las
elecciones generales los líderes de
Santa Cruz anunciaron que aún siguen
pendientes de la completa aprobación de
La Ley a partir de este momento
hacemos un cuarto intermedio
levantamos el paro y bloqueos sin
suspender nuestra lucha seguimos en
emergencia en la región más grande de
Bolivia rica en soya la huelga dejó mil
millones de dólares en pérdidas según el
Ministerio de finanzas Mire ya yo
andaban nervioso ansioso medio Bravo
medio triste Pero por fin hoy una buena
noticia que volvemos a la normalidad los
resultados del censo se entregarán en
septiembre por lo que podrán aspirar
nuevos representantes políticos y
obtener asignaciones económicas para la
región